mom Phineas and Ferb are making a title
sequence there's a hundred and four days
there are two months worth of paper in
the air right now and the calendar
started in June that is a lot of
vacation and not a lot of Education and
that is a sin also littering I love this
opening theme song truly but man things
have changed lyrics now would be
something like scrolling through
tick-tock are yelling a twit or
scrolling for another hour so live life
a do stuff kids and stay off my lawn
also all those things are super
dangerous and should never be shown to
impressionable young children and
apparently it's super important to take
care of them little well that's the
easiest game of find Frankenstein's
brain that I've ever seen elephant
cruelty what is this a flipbook of
everything thing that happens in this
entire show all crammed into a 50-second
intro with flecks like this this show
better be hell or worth it the moment
you realize that Phineas and Ferb's
heads are shaped like the first letters
of the name on purpose and it's been in
the title sequence this whole time but
you never noticed it until you had to
write stupid sins for the show and it
kind of blew your mind but then you
didn't want to admit you never saw it
before now so you wrote a run-on sense
about it cliche having your nickname be
swampy behold the birth of Karen having
to parallel park in your own driveway
seriously how'd that car even get in
there
so Ferb what do you want to do today
Phineas has yet to hit his voice change
imagine if he went through a voice
change halfway through the first season
and sounded completely different glad
that'll never happen I hate it when
things I love go through voice changes
unsubscribe what about Perry what does
he want to do how many kids watch this
show and immediately wanting platypus
for their birthday only to find out
they're illegal to own which leads them
to realize this entire show is a lie
what a horrible thing to do to children
everywhere not like that one we wrote at
the State Fair state fairs
please exit to the left and by left he
beans right
rollercoaster marshals what are you
doing hauling a useless lamp out into
the daylight what does it look like no I
can't judge them all right now if you go
can you see Jeremy's there yeah he
totally smiled at me last time I was
there she hits the mall phone in boys
teenage girl cliche trifecta in less
than five seconds flat she's basically
the Usain Bolt of the adolescent cliche
Olympics since we've already mentioned
the casual animal abuse I'll just add
that this line could easily squeeze
through those bar gaps clothing so stiff
it doesn't obey gravity is disgusting
Perry apparently attended the Scooby Doo
Academy of animating secret doors so
that they are completely visible in a
know a secret
as always Agent P it is imperative that
your cover identity as a mindless
domestic pet remains intact I mean if
you want to keep something secret
perhaps choose an animal that is a legal
domestic pet we have cereal
we have no cereal the forms all seem to
be in order although I've never seen
them filled out in crayon before so
Phineas is brilliant enough to build a
roller coaster with a blowtorch and
peanut butter but still writes his arse
backward maybe I should just add ten
cents for this works and let's do
another ten for Sponge Bob level
ridiculousness in the real world and
then maybe ten more for evil lair is
obvious cliche it's ten plus ten plus
ten carry the seven thirteen cents ooh
can't wait to see the other body part
buttons really worked out all the bugs
that is not an answer to the perfectly
reasonable question you just asked
yourself putting up a poster with one
staple Candace's upset because the
poster is gone and maybe she should be
mad at herself for not taking the poster
with her considering catching her
brother in the act of shenanigans is her
shtick you'd think she'd learn in an
adapt by now control C control V control
C control V with new hair I know this is
just a cartoon but this is giving me a
serious case of vertigo and not the good
Jimmy Stewart plays dress-up with Kim
Novak kind either this show is next
level insane and makes literally no
sense but there's also a city of people
and I find it super hard to believe none
of them would call the police
to report a dangerous roller coaster
circling the interstate all of this
would be in the news also doctor flu
Finn squirts or whatever opens up the
roof to enact his evil plan and I'm just
wondering where everything else in his
lap has gone I mean this looks fun and
all but you clearly built this thing to
bypass this building earlier spoof in
spurts is going to use a magnet to move
the city
because he covered it with tinfoil
there's only one problem doof ball
tinfoil is made of aluminum and not
affected by magnets plus I brought my
dinosaur that eats forcefield dogs or or
turn it off okay I give up what am I
supposed to be looking at look up
problem solved
I know cartoons play fast and loose with
physics and stuff but even cartoons have
a they survive this threshold right
because I feel like these kids would
only be identifiable by their dental
records by this point of the ride you
know if that thing crashes to earth
Candace is in charge yes I do know that
but how do you consider you weren't
anywhere near that conversation she
charged my capitalism I told you they
weren't there oh hi boys hi mom
I'm calling it this mom is a robot with
zoom vision who can only see the tree
trunk that is being shown to us because
in reality from where she stands in the
driveway she'd see the entire tree and
easily notice the flaming roller coaster
10 feet above the boys heads well he's a
platypus they don't do much they're the
only mammals to lay eggs the spiny
anteaters will be very disappointed to
hear that every single thing Ferb said
in this episode is a lot
a minute ago I was really confused about
life and then grandma came in with their
wonderful and affecting roller coaster
story and now everything's great again
for some reason you all want to wear the
cinemasins pitch for EM on your body so
we slapped that car on some new merchant
in the store posters hoodies tanks socks
leggings click on the merch below the
YouTube player or click the store link
get cinemasins comm so Ferb what do you
want to do today the same thing we do
every night pinky what you doing what
you doing ok I'm gonna go get the snakes
why did it have to be snakes snakes
rollercoaster I worry about you
sometimes Candace